this video is sponsored by Skillshare
the first 500 to use the link in the
description get a two month free trial
within a country wealth and power are
almost always concentrated in just a few
small regions in the US 37 of the 75
highest earning counties lie in the
north eastern corridor between
Washington DC and Boston and 54% of
startups are first financed in just five
metropolitan areas trace the coasts and
there you will find the rich and
powerful China is no exception
the historic political capital of DC is
Beijing the bustling financial center of
New York is Shanghai and the fast paced
innovative Silicon Valley is the
southern city of Shenzhen together it
Hong Kong Macau Guangzhou and several
other cities form the Pearl River Delta
one of the wealthiest and most vibrant
parts of China and one of the most
important to the world economy it's home
to the third fifth and seventh busiest
container ship ports it's where your
iPhone came from and where it will
eventually end up but while these are
among China's most internationally open
connected and capitalist cities they're
also the most disconnected domestically
despite being part of China Hong Kong
and Macau have separate governments laws
and freedoms residents of the two
special administrative regions require a
permit to cross the border into the
mainland and vice versa
legally their islands and doing business
across them involves a sea of
bureaucracy at least until now china
plans to integrate all these cities into
one greater Bay Area a mega city 58%
bigger than the entire Tokyo
metropolitan area San Francisco's Bay
Area is home to about 7 million people
China's almost 70 it hopes to rival both
Silicon Valley and Wall Street at the
same time with an economy already the
size of South Korea or Russia but many
argue there's another hidden motivation
behind China's plan
the train from West Kowloon in downtown
Hong Kong the Fujian station and
Shenzhen mainland China takes just 14
minutes but in those 26 kilometers
almost everything changes
British electrical outlets are replaced
with the type one used in Australia and
New Zealand sites like YouTube Twitter
and Facebook stop working thanks to the
Great Firewall the Hong Kong dollar
becomes the Chinese yen and the average
income drops from 46 to 30 thousand to
u.s. dollars all of this is due to Hong
Kong's unique and complicated history on
June 30th 1997 the United Kingdom
officially withdrew from the territory
after a hundred and fifty six years of
governance and on July 1st Hong Kong was
returned to China but not without
compromise the sino-british joint
declaration stated that although Hong
Kong would exist under the sovereignty
of China it was guaranteed its own
Constitution capitalist and legal
systems for 50 years Hong Kong will be
directly under the authority of the
central People's Government of the
People's Republic of China and will
enjoy a high degree of autonomy except
in foreign and defense Affairs one
country two systems' likewise the
Portuguese and Chinese government's
signed the joint declaration on the
question of Macau but with separate
detached government's come separate
detached economies for a region so
dependent on trade and tourism
travelling between cities is remarkably
complicated while the train from Hong
Kong to Shenzhen only takes 14 minutes
it also requires a lengthy immigration
and customs process first by going
through security
then the Hong Kong departure procedure
and finally receiving mainland arrival
clearance which requires a separate visa
on the other side of Hong Kong the
longest sea crossing in the world
connects to Macau and the mainland city
of Zhuhai
but this 19 billion dollar bridge which
took eight years to build is
surprisingly quiet in 2018 36 million
people visited Macau 88 percent of whom
came from the mainland or
komm but only about 1 million total
entered through the bridge the crossing
is an amazing feat of engineering but
also a bureaucratic nightmare because
all three territories have separate laws
and regulations crossing the bridge
requires three separate insurance
policies in Hong Kong car insurance is
required to cover twelve point seven
four million u.s. dollars in damages on
the mainland a tiny eighteen thousand
one hundred and seventy two dollars and
in Macau a minimum of 180 5520 for such
a huge difference makes creating a
single unified policy extremely
difficult and because of their British
and Portuguese influence Hong Kong and
Macau drive on the left side of the road
but the main bridge section is located
in mainland waters so hong kong drivers
have to switch to the right hand side as
they enter the link bridge even though
that's still in hong kong territory
travel briefly in an undersea tunnel
allowing ships to pass overhead and then
change back to the left side if they
enter Macau making things even more
complicated there's a quota on private
cars of course immigration and customs
and a toll which if you pay in cash has
to be Chinese yen imagine how much
harder it would be to work in San
Francisco if crossing the Golden Gate
required a visa permit changing sides of
the road twice and a few insurance
policies oh and don't forget to pay with
Mexican pesos these inefficiencies are
especially pronounced in an area so rich
with startups
and large consumer markets doctors
lawyers and investors for example are
often blocked from doing business across
borders despite their huge economic
potential if not legally then out of
confusion or frustration Hong Kong and
San Francisco have some of the world's
most expensive rent the former however
is surrounded by other terribly
expensive cities Palo Alto San Jose
Berkeley and so on Hong Kong on the
other hand has lots of cheap labor for
Chinese increasingly service based
economy right across the border waiting
to be tapped into the Chinese government
sees this as a major opportunity the
Bay Area plan first announced in 2016
and just released in February is not one
but a series of steps to connect these
cities and make use of their vast
differences Macau will continue to be
the Las Vegas of the East thanks to its
geographically central location and
relaxed gambling laws Hong Kong a global
intermediary allowing foreign firms to
invest in China and increasingly for
Chinese companies to access the wider
world its airports one of the busiest in
the world and now in the process of
building a third runway will act as a
gateway to the rest of the region
already 14 of its 75 million passengers
a year end up travelling to nearby
cities and Cathay Pacific is considering
selling to in one plane tickets which
include train or ferry travel to and
from the airport
Shenzhen meanwhile will serve as China's
Silicon Valley home to some of the
country's biggest companies including
DJI 10 cent and BYD
finally Guangzhou as the capital of the
entire Guangdong province is the
administrative and political center and
connecting them all are the first parts
of the plan the train from Hong Kong to
the mainland the Hong Kong Macau zhuhai
bridge whose details will hopefully be
worked out and another currently in
construction will connect Shenzhen to
the other side of the mainland now as
these cities become more linked together
wealth will spread outward the Hong Kong
University of Science and Technology has
announced a second campus on the
mainland and many companies are
investing in property across the border
in anticipation of the plan already
Shenzhen is nowhere near the cheap
source of labour it once was and some
cities will likely benefit more than
others but with 70 million people there
will long be plenty of workers in
surrounding areas the economic case for
the plan is therefore hard to refute but
so is the concerning trend that has
followed remember that before you can
get on the train from Hong Kong to
Shenzhen you first have to pass mainland
immigration that means a portion of the
terminal in the middle of downtown Hong
Kong is controlled by mainland
authorities and governed by mainland
now as an isolated event this would be
easy to dismiss as a mere convenience
for faster travel after all it's quite
similar to how the Chinese government
leases part of its Schengen port to Hong
Kong but this is occurring against a
much larger backdrop in 2014 the Chinese
government changed Hong Kong's election
rules limiting the democratic power of
its people to elect their chief
executive to which Hongkongers took to
the streets with our iconic yellow
umbrellas later during a football match
Hong Kong fans booed at China's national
anthem it ended in a tense 0 to 0 with
Chinese police wearing riot gear warning
the crowd not to insult the song the
People's Republic then passed a law
which made doing so illegal
and although Hong Kong is entitled to
its own laws there's an exception a
special section of its constitution
which China has the power to add to or
remove from more recently the Hong Kong
government is proposing changing its
extradition laws to allow some suspected
criminals to be sent to the mainland for
prosecution both the UK and US
government's have warned that Hong
Kong's autonomy is at risk but it's also
clear the world is woefully unprepared
for a China which builds not walls but
bridges it's unlikely that either
country would risk raising tensions any
further meanwhile political unity and
economic growth are China's absolute
highest priorities it will argue the
redundancies of Hong Kong and Macau
separation loses everyone time and money
many locals in turn will argue that
those separations are exactly what makes
their home so great
China will argue that no part of the
greater Bay Area plan fundamentally
changes its relationship with the
regions that protesters are overreacting
and skeptics will argue gradual symbolic
changes are exactly how freedom is
usually lost Hong Kong is unlike any
other place on earth a culture within a
culture set to expire in 2047 when it's
promised autonomy ends but the new era
has in many ways already begun there are
about 170 9,000
Hongkongers worth a million US dollars
which divided by its 427 square miles
means you'd only need to walk an average
of four meters to cross paths with a
millionaire but as the world moves
towards an automation based economy the
greater Bay Area will need to invest in
high-skilled workers to maintain its
advantage and truthfully we should all
be learning skills to survive in the new
economy and a great way to get started
is with skill share in short bite-sized
videos like this one you can watch me
teach you how to make your own animated
videos or business casual show you how
to invest in the stock market or Thomas
Frank teach you how to do more of the
learning thing and less of the say
playing video games thing there are
25,000 classes in business design
programming you name it and you can try
it today with a two month free trial
with the link in the description for the
first 500 people